in this video we will learn what is
Vector search why it is becoming so
important for businesses and how to get
started with building production quality
Vector search services with Google Cloud
vertex AI did you know that you use
dozens of different Vector search
Services every day Vector search
technology is now one of the most
essential component in AIML Services
just like the relational databases in it
systems for example Google uses Vector
search to organize data across its
various services such as Google search
YouTube and Google Play to provide
search results and recommendations that
are relevant to
users Vector search can also be used for
search and recommendation of different
types of things in businesses such as
products users user activities
conversations music and videos and
signals from iot sensors in the age of
generative AI V to search is becoming
more and more a crucial part for for
example this demo uses Factor search to
find product items matching the query
handmade accessories with black and
white beads from 6 million product items
in milliseconds notably it does not use
any item titles descriptions or tags for
the search instead it Reves the result
by looking only at the item images this
kind of multimodal search is made
possible with a combination of vector
search and gen AI
models you may be Wonder
what the difference is between
traditional databases and Vector search
technology in traditional it systems
most data is organized as structured or
tabular data using simple keywords
labels and categories in databases and
keyword-based search
engines unlike the traditional it
systems modern AI Based Services use a
simple data structure called embedding
which is a special type of
vector let's see how AI organizes data
using embeddings
once trained with a specific content
like text images or any content AI
creates a space called iding space which
is essentially a map of the content
meaning AI can identify the location of
each content on the map that's what
embedding is let's take an example where
a text discusses movies music and actors
with a distribution of 10% 2% and 30%
respectively in this case the AI can
create embedding with three values .1 02
and 3 in three dimensional
space and AI can put the content with
similar meanings crossly together in
this space please keep in mind that this
is a simplified example for Illustrated
purposes in reality embedding spaces can
have hundreds or thousands of Dimensions
which can capture sat differences or
nuances in the content and sort it into
an almost infinite number of different
categories let's see how the real your
ambing space look like here you can see
the 6 million images are sorted into
extremely specific categories by their
meaning providing a glimps into the
human level intelligence that gen model
has using Vector search with this
embedding space you can find items by
their meanings in milliseconds which was
almost impossible with traditional
databases and keyword based search
engines Vector search and embeddings are
now playing a crucial role in creating a
new web of human computer
interaction AI organizes data into
embeddings which represent what users
are really looking for the meaning of
content or the essential signatures of
your business
data vectors which can find these
embeddings in milliseconds creating a
new level of user experience that is
becoming the new
standard as Vector search becomes as
essential to many it system as databases
many people are looking for ways to
build production ready Vector search
services
Google has a long history in this area
let's explore how Google has developed
its highly scalable and reliable Vector
search infrastructure which underpins
many major Google services embeddings
are vectors lists of hundreds of numbers
to find similar embeddings we can simply
calculate the distance between two
embeddings and select the closer ones
but calculating this for millions of
emings can be challenging for example if
you have 8 million emings with 700
Dimensions you will need to perform 8
million time 700
calculations this would take tens of
seconds researchers are studying a
technique called approximate nearest
neighbor orn to speed up Vector search
Ann uses Vector quantization to divide
the space into multiple spaces with a
threee structure similar to an index in
a database this enables very fast and
scalable search with billions of
embeddings
in 2020 Google research published scan a
newn algorithm that is considered one of
the best in the industry and the most
important foundation for search and
recommendation in major Google services
like Google search YouTube and many
others scan is the foundation of
Google's business user experience and
core competency in pursuing its mission
to organize the W's information and make
it universally accessible and useful
Google Cloud can now take full advantage
of Google's scan based V search
technology with vertic AI search it is a
fully managed service that makes it easy
to add edings to an index and perform
bracingly fast Vector searches is a
simple search query Vector search offers
not only Top Notch performance but also
high scalability and reliability making
it a solid foundation for Google scale
Enterprise services with its tight
integration with Google groud services
like bigquery vertic AI edings API and
feature store you can quickly build and
operate a production ml Ops pipeline for
data extraction embedding generation and
sharing and embedding search all in one
platform let's take a look at how Vector
search can be easily used for building a
Production Service in Enterprises for
example what if you want to show similar
items to a specific item the uses
specify first you get embeddings for
each item second build an index on
Vector search Vis the edings then you
can just run a query on Vector search to
find similar items by their names that's
it let's get started this is the big
query table of the items and their names
in this example let's simply use amben
for the item names you can also use
descriptions or images to capture more
detailed meanings with the
emings onary it's so easy to get
embeddings for texts just use ml. embed
text function in your query so you will
get the edings for the specified text
column despite of the Simplicity what
you are getting here is the
state-ofthe-art LM power text embeddings
that means they are carefully organized
in the embedding space with the human
level intelligence and commonsense as we
saw
Ario then export the ambic as a Jon file
on the ground
St this is the exported Json file each
embedding Ro has 768 Dimensions that
represents the meaning of an item name
next create an index with Vector store
you can specify the cloud storage path
of the Json file along with the
parameters suggest the dimensions number
of items to fetch similarity measure
type Etc if you are building an index
with small or midsized item table this
process should finish within some
minutes the last thing is to deploy the
index on an index Endo that receives the
query request from your front end and
execute the vector sech now it's ready
to serve you can run a query by passing
and embeding of the specified item so
you will receive a list of similar items
within tens of
milliseconds please note that this is
not just a keyword search on the item
names this is a so-called semantic
search finding items by understanding
the meaning of the names with the power
of
llm so you can expect much better user
experience for exploring and sporting
relevant
items that's it once you get the
embeddings based on what you want to do
then using Vector search is quite simple
and doesn't require any rocket science
as a result saw Vector search have
already been deployed in many customers
production systems for example Mercury
the popular Marketplace app uses the
technology for showing product
recommendations
they were able to build and deploy the
system within one month with one person
significantly reduce the time and cost
for AI service development would you
like to bring the Fess with AI to your
business please go to this URL to get
started with vector
sech